oh you guys see those fireworks during
the questioning of the deputy AG and
that House hearing today rod Rosenstein
has been overseeing the Russian
investigation for ever since jeff
sessions notorious recusal and GOP
lawmakers didn't hesitate to vent their
frustrations with his handling of the
probe you wrote the memo saying that
Comey should be fired and you sign the
FISA extension for Carter page so my
question is to you seems like you should
be recused from this more so than Jeff
session just because you were involved
in making decisions affecting both
prongs of this investigation why haven't
you done that congressman I can assure
you that we're propria to recuse I'll be
more than happy if you have evidence of
wrongdoing by any member of the Trump
campaign campaign presented to the damn
grand jury if you have evidence that
this president acted inappropriately
presented to the American people
whatever you got finish it the hell up
because this country is being torn apart
I think the best thing we can do is
finish it appropriately and reach a
conclusion and I certainly agree with
you sir that people should not jump to
conclusions without seeing the evidence
did you read the FISA application before
you signed it not going to comment about
any FISA okay so you why are you keeping
information from Congress person I am
not keeping any information from
Congress that it's approved your
statement that I'm personally keeping
information from you trying to conceal
information toward the boss mr. Rosas
nine that's correct
and my job is to make sure that we
respond to your concerns we have sir so
I appreciate your concerns and I think
the house represented is going to say
otherwise but your use of this to attack
me prided you son wrong you got seven
days to get your act together and I
wonder why you won't give us what we've
asked for sir I certainly hope that your
colleagues are not under that impression
that is not accurate sir it is accurate
we have caught you hiding chairman we
allow those it's time anyone else get
nervous during that exchange I was very
uncomfortable joining me now for
analysis great panel of course Fox News
contributor former federal prosecutor
Andy McCarthy just wrote a great piece
by the way former whitewater deputy
independent counsel Saul Eisenberg and
former FBI nationals
folks person John in or le great to see
all of you saw let's start with you you
were annoyed by Jim Jordans questioning
which you found to be badgering I gotta
say I was watching in my radio studio
and I kind of winced because when you
have to interrupt the witness it makes
it makes your case not look that strike
just let him answer the question then
have a you know have a have a quick
follow-up but I think he's worried about
not having enough time there they have
such limited amount of time that he
probably got frustrated but was that a
fatal mistake on the part of Jordan why
do think is a fatal mistake I just think
he's you know he went to school at the
Teddy Kennedy School of Congressional
cross examination you ask a hostile
question and then you immediately
interrupt the person that you're
questioning
so my objection is not to the substance
of what he asked he's allowed to ask
anything he wants it is to the badgering
but the the larger question here about
this whole exercise of bashing
Rosenstein is something that Andy has
spoken to several times in his columns
Andy McCarthy and spoke to it a couple
of days ago President Trump has the
absolute authority to order rod
Rosenstein to turn over anything and
everything to the Congress and if he did
it and Rosen Stein didn't want to do it
he could resign or if you refused to do
it
the president could fire him why hasn't
he done that let's ask Andy that Andy
what's the delay
why hasn't President Trump just said
turn the documents over that's not
prejudicing the case or he doesn't look
like he's defensive just it's
transparency why why won't the president
say to Rosenstein enough for these
continuing resolutions that they keep
passing that are meaningless in Congress
they passed a resolution over compelling
you to release the document they're not
gonna release the documents that was
clear today to me so why won't the
president demand that they be finally
released get this thing on the road show
on the road it's a great question Laura
and I I appreciate Saul bringing it up
you know the great irony I thought of
the hearing was my friend Jim Jordan
really laying into
rhod Rosenstein saying you're the boss
these people work for you and you know
the elephant in the room is that Rosen
Stein works for Trump and it precisely
the point you make is is true Trump can
order this so what we understand is that
he's gotten advice I don't think it's
particularly good advice that because
he's been under investigation for
obstruction and because the critics of
Trump have conflated in the in the
public mind the Republican Congress's
pursuit of what went on with the agents
who conducted these investigations and
Muller's investigation that if Trump
acts to force disclosure and help
Congress here he's effectively
obstructing justice now I think that's
nuts I don't see a legal obstruction
right now I think that's where they're
at that's what they're worried about
John there are so many things in this
hearing that were wild one of them was
when he was asked resist I was asked you
know what about this FISA warrant and he
wouldn't answer the question about
whether he read it and then he said well
this you know struck didn't brief me and
he went through the others Moyers didn't
brief me but he wouldn't
answer the question about did you
actually read this FISA warrant and he
the kept saying well you basically don't
understand and I don't I I don't he also
said I don't supervise you know I have a
hundred thousand employees so he wasn't
looking over the shoulder of Peter
struck at every every moment but he said
he wants to root out any corruption
that's there if he had read the warrant
he would have said I read the warrant he
obviously didn't read the warrant or
maybe glanced over it's so long ago we
can't remember the specifics which is
why he's not commenting I'll tell you
this whole process is moving so
incredibly slow at this point DOJ has to
stop with the Glacial performance and
recognize the American people want to
know what's going on
speed it up already let's get the
answers out there and trey Gowdy went
that's crazy on that it's like Cathy
didn't he decided Saul not to ask a
question but to take his time to make
sure that he got he got quoted and the
soundbite was used
most evening newscasts and cable and all
over media social media today get this
thing wrapped up what is taken so long
give us the documents and then there was
a moment when Jordan was pressing
another matter about Peter struck I want
to play it and have Saul's reaction
let's watch why did you tell Peter
struck not to enter our questions
yesterday when I asked when I asked
Peter struck if he'd ever communicated
with Glenn Simpson he gave us the answer
he gave us dozens of times on advice of
FBI counsel I can't answer that question
why couldn't you answer that question
sure and I appreciate your sincere
concerns but I didn't computer to strike
any instructions how do I know sir I
mean I interviewed mr. struck I didn't
so I can't for you didn't work for us so
I don't think Rosen Stein came off well
today at all I thought he came off as
very defensive very flip but he played
the victim card you're personally
attacking me you're mean to me in the
media like welcome to the big leagues
buddy you know you're deputy AG it's
pretty hot right now but he kept saying
well there's just all these people who
work in the Department of Justice this
was the this is the biggest case the
Russia case but the Hillary email case
these two things dovetailed together
because of this one agent he had a duty
to find out what happened well keep in
mind here I I I think he did he did
better than you think he did but keep in
mind two really important things I'm
glad you focused on this because Rosa
Stein made two points number one I'm not
the one and nobody at DOJ
as opposed to FBI which is in the DOJ
but nobody in Rosenstein shop told Peter
Strock what to say or not to say and
also we made it very clear he had
nothing to do with the redactions
including this latest outrageous
redaction that they didn't find out
about until the inspector general's
report came out about the will stop him
he didn't have anything to do with that
when he found out and when he was told
there were redactions he brought in this
US attorney from Chicago but it brings
up an interesting point there appears
that for many years on and off there's
been a rogue al
in FBI leadership that obstructs these
kind of investigations and obviously
it's outrageous that that text message
was not sent to the Congress and the
question is what's what's going to be
done about it because I think DOJ should
do something about that yeah Andy are
there any repercussions for what was
done
I mean redacting don't worry basically
I'll take care of it meaning he's net
you know he it's not gonna be a problem
Trump's not gonna be a problem and that
doesn't go to the Congress of course and
you know this is the problem I think
that Rosenstein has I think for example
I wondered if he had ever prepared a
witness before because a lot of times it
seemed to me his answers were sensible
but the smirk on his face was really
off-putting but on this particular he
says that he strongly supports the
disciplining of agents who have
committed misconduct he endorsed IG
Horowitz's report but you know you got
to put your money where your mouth is
and it's impossible to be credible and
say at the same time we're giving you
all this cooperation and when we find
somebody who withhold stuff we don't do
anything to discipline them yeah you
know what what I'm looking for for some
of these officials it
why isn't he angry about this like he
just he seems it's all about him like
you're again here mean to me you were
mean to me in the press and their
personal attacks if this happened at the
FBI which it did you had these people
burrowed into the system who hated Trump
they wanted to make sure that Hillary
didn't get it didn't you know didn't
ultimately get prosecuted and they were
gonna make sure by hell or high water
that Trump is gonna have problems why
isn't this guy Rosenstein angry I don't
know because I'll tell you in the FBI I
held a lot of leadership positions no
matter what somebody did underneath me
I'm the boss I'm responsible for it and
you better believe I would have been
angry after the fact when I confronted
whoever did what yeah it was just the
buck stops here no I guess not it's like
oh I have to meet well they let him out
they led they led struck out don't
forget a couple weeks ago he was let out
escorted out
shame yeah but he still works there
though I mean you don't know it's not
like he's gone he's sort of over there
yeah like what but he was moved to like
Human Resources after the lovebirds
tomorrow we need human resources yeah
okay guys this is a human resources yeah
all right guys thanks so much